this is the show that as long as you're
doing what's right for the consumer
you're going to love this show
but if you're in the financial world and
you are winning and the consumer is not
winning you're going to continually hate
this show because I'm going to call you
out car leasing is the most expensive
way on the planet to drive a vehicle
leasing your car is the worst car
financial deal out there Smart Money
Magazine Consumer Reports and Dave
Ramsey and yet a bunch of you fleeced
your car last year and a bunch of you
they're out there selling cars every day
aren't really selling them you're just
renting them to people whole life life
insurance is the payday lender of the
middle-class it's screwing you you need
to get term insurance in place and get
rid of that crap you need to pay cash
for your car or not buy it you can be a
student without a student loan don't add
to the 1.2 trillion dollar student loan
debt crisis that we have in the United
States because we the taxpayers are so
freakin stupid that we are guaranteeing
eighteen-year-olds loans with no
collateral up to a hundred thousand
bucks we're idiots
just because we're idiots and letting
you do it doesn't mean you have to be an
idiot and partake go to a school you can
afford and pay cash why would you ever
buy anything on 18 percent Interest why
would you draw your self esteem from the
color of a piece of plastic in your
pocket are you really that freaking
shallow
see this is the kind of stuff we say on
the show it upsets people in the banking
business the car business the insurance
business which gives us great joy by the
way we've been doing it for twenty years
and we take great pleasure and upsetting
these people because they're screwing
you oh did I mention payday lenders the
scum of the earth if you're a payday
lender if your son is a payday lender
and he's 40 years old take him out to
the woodshed and whip him and tell him
to get a real job and quit ripping
people off
you're ripping people 840 percent
interest any idiot can figure out 840
this is a service that poor people need
because poor people can't borrow money
yeah so you screw them that's awesome
that's awesome you just completely mess
them over because you can you call that
providing a service that's like a tote
the note car lot where you pay for the
car 16 times before you get the car
owned absolutely ridiculous
rent to own oh by the way three of those
payments and you could have bought that
washer and dryer on Craigslist stupid
think about it
think about it quit falling for this
stuff so guess what oh and don't don't
forget don't forget the greatest ripoff
of all not really but one of the
greatest my favorite to pick on the
timeshare
yes let's rent our vacation and pay
interest on it for the rest of our lives
what a dumb idea so all of those people
just loved Dave Ramsey not really but 8
million of you do because I take up for
you you're why I'm here not those people
this is the Dave Ramsey chef
you